on a pris un avocat et nous dit de faire
une demande d'expulsion
je m'appelle Inès Viviani je me vois
bien property manager chez anti-squat je
connaissais pas la protection par
l'occupation c'est quelque chose qui a
du sens donc j'ai tout de suite sauté
sur votre annonce
le rôle du résidente manager c'est de
recruter les résidents
vous partez désinstaller dans l'immeuble
et s'assurer qu'ils ont bien compris le
règlement pour ça il faut s'installer
avec eux les managers sont soumis au
même règle que les résidents pas le
droit de s'absenter plus de deux jours
sans autorisation pas plus de invités
pas de fait pas d'enfant pas d'enfant
S
[Musique]
qui sont résidents et pas locataire
ou quoi
vous avez signé le contrat au bout de
trois avertissements vous savez ce qui
se passe l'immeuble il le protège il
l'entretienne mais ils sont pas chez eux
personne doit devoir
S
c'est toi qui t'ai mise toute seule dans
la merde
c'est nous